So we've got three functions
graphed right over here.
And then we have three
equations right over here
that could describe
these functions.
And once again, we
need to figure out
which ones will match
with which other ones.
And I encourage you to pause
this video right now and think
about it.
So let's go equation
by equation.
And at least let's try to write
them in a form or at least
look at parts of them that will
make it a little easier for us
to figure out which
ones match up.
So let's look at this
first one right over here.
So this first one,
instead of just taking
the trouble of multiplying
all of this out,
I really care about
the highest degree term
and maybe the
lowest degree term.
So let me just try
to figure those out.
So I could rewrite
that one as y is
equal to-- the highest
degree term is essentially
going to be, we're going to
take the product of these four
expressions: negative 1/11
times x minus 5 times this times
this.
So if we take the highest
degree part of each of them,
that's going to give us
our highest degree terms.
So it's going to be
negative 1/11 times x times
x squared times x squared.
So that's going to be
x to the fifth, right?
x squared times x squared
is x to the fourth times x
is x to the fifth.
Negative 1/11 x to the fifth.
And then it's going to
be plus a bunch of stuff.
And then our lowest degree term
is going to be, let's see--
It's going to be negative
1/11 times negative
5, which is positive 5/11.
Actually let me just
write it this way.
Plus negative 1/11 times
negative 5 times positive 10
times 2x.
I guess we could work this out.
This is what, positive 100/11.
But let's just
leave it like this.
That's going to be our
lowest degree term.
I just took the lowest degree
from each of these expressions
that we're going to be
multiplying together.
And so, this is another
way of viewing it.
And what's useful about this
one is we could immediately
think about the
end behavior here.
So what do I mean
by end behavior?
Well we've covered this already.
Let's look at the coefficient
on the highest degree term.
And let's also think about
whether the highest degree
term is odd or even.
Since we're dealing
with an odd degree
polynomial-- this
is x to the fifth--
and this coefficient on
the highest degree term
is negative, this
is going to have
end behavior like
negative x to the third.
And what would negative
x to the third look like?
Well when x is
really negative, it's
going to be really positive.
Because x to the third is going
to be really negative, but then
you're multiplying
it times a negative.
And then when x is really
positive, x to the 3rd
is going to be
even more positive,
but we have a
negative out front,
so it's going to
be really negative.
So this function is going
to look something like this,
and it's going to do some
crazy things in between.
So which of these
look like that?
Well let's see... f starts high,
then it goes high up again.
So it's not that one.
g starts low and ends up high.
This starts high, ends up low.
So the only one that's left--
this actually kind of plays
tricks with the eye--
the only one that's left
is the dotted purple
one which is-- actually
do they even have
a label on this?
Well we'll call that one h.
That one is h.
And let me highlight it,
because I know it's hard to see.
So this one.
This one right over here.
Notice: end behavior.
It starts for very
negative values
and has a very high
value for our function.
Then it does all sorts of
crazy things in between.
And you can actually
see that it clearly
has one, two, three,
four, five roots.
But that's not what we're really
concerned with for this sake.
And then after it does
all that crazy stuff,
as x gets really positive,
the value of the function
becomes really negative.
So its end behavior is like
negative x to the third.
So we can feel confident that
this function right over here
is h of x.
Now, in other videos I've
looked at the intercepts.
But what is the
y-intercept for this one?
Well, when x equals 0, this
whole thing is equal to 0.
Because the lowest degree
term isn't a constant.
It has an x in it.
So when x is 0, this
whole thing is 0.
And that's consistent.
Actually all three of these
have a y-intercept of 0.
And you see that's
because all three of them
have a lowest degree
term that involves an x.
So we can really just
concern ourselves
with the highest degree terms.
So now let's think
about the next function.
And I'm gonna give myself
some real estate here.
I don't want to scroll
down just because I
want to be able to
look at the graph.
So let's look at-- oh
my phone's ringing.
This is more important.
Let me work on this video-- So
this next one right over here.
Let's just think about
what it might look like.
It would look like y is equal
to-- its highest degree term
is 110 times x squared
times x squared.
So positive 110 times x
squared times x squared,
which is x to the fourth.
And then plus a
bunch of other stuff.
So what's its end
behavior going to be?
Well it has an even exponent
on its highest degree.
Or it's an even
degree polynomial.
And the coefficient on
that highest degree term
is positive.
So it's going to
have end behavior
like positive x squared.
So when x is really negative,
the value of the function
is going to be really positive.
And then when x is
really positive,
the value of the function is
going to be really positive.
And it might do some
kind of crazy things
in between, because this
obviously isn't x squared.
It has all sorts of
crazy terms there.
So which of these
functions looks like that?
Well let's see.
Our f has that,
when x gets really
negative it gets
really positive.
And when x gets really positive,
it gets really positive.
And it's the only one that
has that type of behavior.
So we can say fairly confidently
that f of x is this function.
Or this function is f of x.
And then once again,
deductive reasoning, we
can think that this
last one is g of x.
That this last one right
over here is g of x.
But let's verify it.
So if we were trying to think
about its highest degree term,
it would be y is
equal to 1/11 times
x times x squared
times x squared.
So 1/11 x to the fifth.
And then plus all sorts
of other business.
So here you have an odd
degree-- it's a fifth degree--
and you have a
positive coefficient
on that fifth degree term.
So it's going to
have end behavior
like positive x to the third.
So when x is really negative,
the value of the function
is going to be really negative.
And when x is positive,
the value of the function
is going to be really positive.
And it's going to do all sorts
of crazy things in between.
So which one looks like that?
Well g looks like that.
When x gets negative,
the value of our function
gets really negative.
As x gets really positive,
the value of our function
becomes really positive.
And it does all sorts
of craziness in between.
So we can feel good
that that one is g of x.